Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Four, Part Two.
Now: how does democracy work, day to day?
Danish democracy is clearly expressed when the Folketing discusses and handles a bill.
It is here that the parties show their different political views and interests.
It is here you hear different views on how Danish society should be organised.
The Folketing's debates on the content of laws are therefore very central to democracy.
In legislation, the Folketing can set the framework for Danish society and for citizens' daily lives.
Both the government and the individual member of the Folketing can put forward bills.
That is, propose a new law or propose to change an existing law.
In practice, however, the government puts forward by far most proposals for laws.
It is often a big job to draft a bill.
And the necessary knowledge and manpower are found especially among the civil servants in the government's ministries.
One or more members of the Folketing can also put forward a proposal for a Folketing resolution, a folketingsbeslutning, which obliges the government to draw up a bill.
A Folketing resolution, like laws, must be passed by a majority in the Folketing.
The idea for a new law, or a change of an existing law, can come from many different places.
The idea can, for example, originally come from a citizen, an association, an interest organisation or a municipality.
They may draw attention to conditions they want changed.
That can then sometimes get a minister or a member of the Folketing to take up the matter.
Other times it is a story in the media that sets the political agenda.
It can for example be a TV programme that makes a politician propose a new law or a change in the law.
Most initiatives do, however, come from the government itself, when it is to put its policy into effect.
Part of the legislation that applies in Denmark also originates in various forms of international cooperation.
Here especially new rules in the EU play a big role.
A bill must go through three readings in the Folketing before it can finally be passed.
The purpose is among other things to ensure that bills are thoroughly handled.
The third reading of the bill ends with a vote.
If there is a majority for the bill, it is passed.
If there is a majority against, it is rejected.
So it is the Folketing, not the government, that adopts a bill.
Votes are only valid if more than half of the members of the Folketing take part, that is at least 90 members.
When the Folketing has passed a bill, both the king and a minister must sign it.
After that, the law is published and can come into force.
Now, direct democracy: referendums and citizens' proposals.
The basic principle in Danish democracy is that the elected politicians are the population's representatives in the Folketing and in the other political assemblies.
That means the politicians make the political decisions on behalf of the population.
In return, the politicians must answer to the voters on election day.
This representative democracy is sometimes supplemented by direct democracy in the form of referendums, folkeafstemninger.
Here the population takes part directly in the democratic decision process.
They can themselves decide whether they are for or against a specific bill.
The constitution lays down that some questions must be decided by a referendum.
That applies, among other things, if the constitution or the voting age is to be changed.
A minority of the Folketing's members of at least one third, that is 60 members, can also demand that a passed bill be put to the voters for approval or rejection.
There are also rules about a referendum when Denmark gives up its right of self-determination, its sovereignty, by taking part in international cooperation.
If fewer than 150 of the Folketing's 179 members, but still a simple majority of at least 90 members, have said yes to Denmark taking part in the international cooperation, a referendum is held on whether Denmark should take part.
This rule has become especially important in connection with Denmark's membership of the EU.
Since the constitution was last changed in 1953, 16 referendums have been held.
More than half of them have been about Denmark's relationship to the EU.
In 2000, a majority, 53 percent, of the voters voted against introducing the common European currency, the euro, in Denmark instead of the Danish krone.
There was a majority in the Folketing for introducing the euro, but the voters said no.
In 2009, a majority, 85 percent, voted for equality between the sexes in the succession to the throne in the royal house, so that men and women have equal right of inheritance to the throne.
In the latest referendum, in 2022, a majority, 66 percent, voted yes to abolishing the opt-out on the EU's defence and security policy.
So since that referendum in 2022, Denmark no longer has an opt-out, a forbehold, on the EU's defence and security policy.
Since 2018, citizens have also had the opportunity to get influence by putting forward so-called citizens' proposals, borgerforslag.
This gives citizens who have the right to vote for the Folketing the possibility to put a proposal forward publicly on the website borgerforslag.dk.
It takes at least four citizens to put forward a citizens' proposal.
Other citizens with the right to vote for the Folketing then have the opportunity to support the proposal.
If a citizens' proposal gets 50,000 supporters within 180 days, the Folketing considers whether the proposal should be put forward in the Folketing.
Citizens are not entitled to have a citizens' proposal put forward in the Folketing.
That is because the constitution says that only members of the Folketing and ministers can put forward proposals in the Folketing.
Most citizens' proposals that have been put forward have not been able to gain a majority in the Folketing.
The citizens' proposal on giving better rights to women giving birth, for example, to have the same midwife throughout the course and to stay overnight at the hospital after the birth, is however an example of a citizens' proposal that was passed in the Folketing.
That happened in 2021.
Here is your recap for Episode Four.
Average turnout at general elections since 2000 is 86 percent, with a range of 84 to 88; Sweden 84, Norway 78, Germany 76, the United Kingdom 65.
Elections must be held at least every four years.
Elections are general, direct and secret, and you must be eighteen with Danish citizenship and a permanent residence in the realm.
A party needs about 20,000 signatures, and an independent candidate 150 voters.
You put one cross, either a personal vote or a party vote.
Seats are distributed by the proportional method.
The electoral threshold is two percent: Sweden and Norway four, Germany five, the Netherlands none.
Since 1973, seven to twelve parties have been elected each time.
A bill needs three readings, at least 90 members voting, and the signatures of the king and a minister.
One third, 60 members, can demand a referendum.
Since 1953 there have been 16 referendums, more than half about the EU: the euro rejected in 2000 with 53 percent, equal succession approved in 2009 with 85 percent, and the defence opt-out abolished in 2022 with 66 percent.
Citizens' proposals started in 2018, and need 50,000 supporters within 180 days.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who adopts a bill?
Option A: The government.
Option B: The Folketing.
[DA] Hvem vedtager et lovforslag?  A: Regeringen  |  B: Folketinget
The answer is B: The Folketing.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Folketinget
Question 2.
Which subject has been the subject of the most referendums in Denmark since 1953?
Option A: The constitution.
Option B: The voting age.
Option C: Denmark's relationship to the EU.
[DA] Hvilket emne har der været afholdt flest folkeafstemninger om i Danmark siden 1953?  A: Grundloven  |  B: Valgretsalderen  |  C: Danmarks forhold til EU
The answer is C: Denmark's relationship to the EU.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Danmarks forhold til EU
Question 3.
Which of the Danish EU opt-outs was the subject of a referendum in 2022?
Option A: The EU's common currency, the euro.
Option B: The EU's common justice and immigration policy.
Option C: The EU's defence and security policy.
[DA] Hvilket af de danske EU-forbehold var der folkeafstemning om i 2022?  A: EU's fælles valuta (euroen)  |  B: EU's fælles rets- og udlændingepolitik  |  C: EU's forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik
The answer is C: The EU's defence and security policy.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: EU's forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik
Question 4.
Does Denmark take part in the EU's defence and security policy?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Deltager Danmark i EU’s forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 5.
Does Denmark have an opt-out on the EU's defence and security policy?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Har Danmark forbehold for EU’s forsvars- og sikkerhedspolitik?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
That's the end of this part.
Well done.